[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
120 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm doing good.
How are you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm all right.
I am slowly dying of the
flu, but not slowly enough
that's going to impede me
from doing the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: You're
surviving it somehow.
MARK MANDEL: I am.
I am.
MELANIE WARRICK: So Mark, who
are we talking to this week?
MARK MANDEL: So this week,
we are going to talk to--
OK.
I've got to get this right--
Nenad Stojanovski.
There we go.
Nenad Stojanovski and Andrew
Hoying talking about Forseti
this week--
the open source
security scanner,
and all sorts of
other cool things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
But as always,
before we do that,
we will tell you about some of
the cool things of the week.
And we will talk
about our question
of the week at the end.
And our question of the week
is, how do I automatically
scan the Docker images in
your Google Cloud Repository
for known vulnerabilities?
MARK MANDEL: Security.
More security.
MELANIE WARRICK: More security.
It's all good.
I bring lots of other
stuff on the ML side.
So we've definitely got to
get some security and Docker
and Kubernetes and all that.
But anyways, cool
things of the week.
So for this week, we wanted
to share about how Shopify
has moved a significant--
actually 50%, I think of
their data center workloads
over to Google Cloud.
And they've been doing a
number of different things
around integration for their
infrastructure in collaboration
with Google Cloud.
So we have a blog
post that we're
going to include in our
show notes as always.
And you'll have
to check that out.
It's really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
They're using a
whole bunch of GKE,
and we know how much
I love Kubernetes.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
It's all about Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
OK, so speaking of
Kubernetes, we'll
go into the next one,
which is Kubernetes
Engine private clusters
are now available in beta.
I'm super excited about this.
Previously, if you were
firing up a GKE cluster,
usually it was public.
IPs were public.
It was available to the
outside world, which
is great for many workloads.
However, if you wanted to hide
this behind a VPC or control
access through a VPC,
that wasn't possible.
But now it is.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is.
It looks like your
notes still have
access to the rest of your
VPC private deployments,
including private access
to Google managed services,
such as gcr.io, Google Cloud
Storage, and Google BigQuery.
And that is in the blog post,
which we will again share.
And another thing we
want to share this week
is the easy HPC clusters
on GCP with Slurm.
So apparently, Slurm
is a workload manager.
And it basically is helping
to launch an auto-scaled Slurm
cluster on a Compute Engine.
So that's what the
integration helps with.
So we have a great
diagram of how that works
and additional information
on this blog that
will explain how to do this.
And we'll make
sure we share that.
MARK MANDEL: I just
like saying Slurm.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
Slurm is a good word.
MARK MANDEL: It's a good word.
I wish I named a project Slurm.
SPEAKER: And it shall be my most
powerful and splendid creation
ever.
And I shall call it Slurm.
[EVIL LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
You missed it.
MARK MANDEL: I missed it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Too late.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So finally, another
cool thing of the week--
there's another
blog post talking
about understanding
your spending
at a glance with Google
Cloud billing reports beta.
So back in episode number 83,
we did do a question of the week
where we talked about how there
were some open and available
dashboards that you could
drop on top of the BigQuery
export of billing
into Data Studio
to give you some more
introspection of what's
happening in billing.
Now there are actually much more
integrated billing dashboards
built in to cloud.google.com.
So if you want to
have a look at those,
those are available for you.
But those export to BigQuery and
visualizing your billing data
with Data Studio--
still available.
Still can do all that.
We've just got some
pre-built stuff
available at beta
inside cloud.google.com.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
It's nice to actually
see some of the trends.
Some of the trends
that they're sharing
are things like cost
group by project,
a different time
aggregation including
daily and monthly
views and so forth.
So definitely check that out.
MARK MANDEL: Useful stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
I think it's time for us to go
and talk to Nenad and Andrew.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good to me.
Today, I am very happy to
have both Nenad Stojanovski
and Andrew Hoying
coming to join us today
from Spotify and
Google, respectively,
to talk to us all about Forseti.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
Nenad, how are you doing today?
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: Good.
Thanks for inviting me, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you for joining us.
Andrew, how are you doing?
ANDREW HOYING: Doing great.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So very happy to have
you both on the call.
Really want to talk to you both
about Forseti, and the project,
and what it does.
But before we do
that, why don't you
tell us a little bit about who
you are, and what do you do?
Nenad, why don't
we start with you?
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: Yeah.
Let's do that.
So as we mentioned,
my name is Nenad.
And I work as a Staff
Security Engineer at Spotify.
So that entails a lot
of security stuff.
And yeah.
I don't think we
have that much time
so that I can go
through all of them.
But that is what it is
with security people.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Andrew?
ANDREW HOYING: Yes.
I'm a Senior Security
Engineer on Google's security
and privacy organization.
My team's focused on securing
Google's use of Google Cloud
Platform, both for
internal services
as well as
public-facing services.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
All right.
Well, so, we brought
you both in today
because we wanted to talk to you
both about the Forseti project.
Why don't you tell us
from your perspective--
and then we'll come
back to you, Nenad--
about, like, what is Forseti?
Like, at a high level, what
problem's it trying to solve?
What does it do?
ANDREW HOYING: Sure.
So Forseti is about making
Cloud easier to secure at scale.
It's relatively simple
for an individual
to secure one project, or
one environment on Cloud,
or 10 environments.
But as you scale to 100 or 1,000
or even 10,000 environments,
becomes very difficult
for even a team of people
to maintain security across
all the disparate settings
and configurations that
we expose for Cloud.
So Forseti is really about
enabling security teams
and enterprises to feel
comfortable and confident
that they're running all
of their different projects
in a way that meets
their security
policies and their security
configuration expectations.
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: Then that--
on top of that,
I think it's also
about having the
ability to scale
towards an agile organization
and have those notifications
and make people are aware of
the misconfigurations they're
making in an actual
agile environment
so that they're on top of their
stuff as soon as it happens
or close to that time.
MELANIE WARRICK: And so Nenad,
since you've used Forseti,
I think one question
that's coming to my mind
are what are some of the
common challenges that you
would have for dealing with
securing something at scale?
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: So that
is a really good question.
So to start with, I mean, yes.
We've use Forseti, but we
also collaborated with Google
on actually making
Forseti what it is today.
And of course, the goal
was in a modern environment
with a huge amount of
servers, you actually
want to take care of the servers
and what is happening on them.
And on top that, of course,
since it is the Cloud,
the Cloud also comes
with a bigger complexity
of having stuff on their metal
and in their local environment
because they end up
using multiple features
from that Cloud.
So one is, yes, moving
to a new platform
and having that secured.
And the second piece
is, of course, how
do you scale your security
with this [INAUDIBLE]
that you want to have
in an agile environment.
So that is kind of how
we ended up using Forseti
and why we actually decided
that it is a good thing
to collaborate with Google.
Because we had one perspective
on what were missing
or what we wanted to have
as a tool, and then Google
had another perspective.
So having those
joined ends up us
having a good tool to do what
we need to do on the Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: So that probably
segues quite nicely into,
like--
so what was the history here?
Where does this project start?
How did this
collaboration come to be?
ANDREW HOYING: Sure.
I can take that
from Google's side
and then have Nenad fill in.
Internally, we had started
using Google Cloud Platform here
at Google, obviously, as soon
as we launched it as a product.
And we had quite a large
deployment on Cloud,
even as the security
team was getting spun up.
So we had a need to sort of
inventory everything that
was currently deployed on Cloud
and get sort of a baseline
configuration.
And then as we've defined
security policies,
we needed a way to notify
different teams and project
owners that they needed
to modify a configuration
or make some setting
change in order to comply
with our security policies.
So we needed some way to scale
very quickly up to a very, very
large environment.
So we initially developed
some internal tooling
to allow us to do that.
But at the same time, we were
hearing from the customer
engineers in our professional
services organization
that customers were running
into this same issue
where they deployed
on Cloud but now
they need some way to monitor
and manage their environment.
So we collaborated--
security collaborated
with professional services
and a few other teams
within Google to
start putting together
this framework for
what became Forseti.
And at the same time, we worked
with our product managers
to look for some of the large
organizations who were already
on Google Cloud who might
want to collaborate on this.
And Spotify stepped
forward and--
because they were building
similar tooling, as Nenad said.
And it ended up being a
great working relationship
to have both an
outside perspective
and our inside perspective on
how to build a tool like this.
MELANIE WARRICK: Does Forseti
come from Norse mythology?
ANDREW HOYING: Yeah.
So we went through a long naming
session, which was really--
was really rather entertaining.
And we had names from
all over the board.
But one thing that
we liked about sort
of the concept of
Forseti is that this
is a overseer sort
of like trying
to maintain security
justice, if you will,
from the Norse mythology.
So the name sort of just stuck
out from all the other ones
that we had from choices.
And everybody ended up
agreeing that it was
a great name for this product.
So that's how it came about.
MARK MANDEL: So
I'm quite curious.
You both also use this
term security at scale.
What does that actually mean?
What does that, like
practically mean?
Like, what sort
of things are you
looking to do when you
do security at scale?
I don't know exactly
what that refers to.
NENAD STOJANOVSKI:
So I think it's
kind of along the lines of
the whole equation on how
many security engineers do you
need per, I don't know, squads?
Teams?
And usually, you can't
have that many people.
Even if you like it,
in the ideal world,
you won't have them.
And the same applies
for resources.
It's like how many resources or
how many security engineers are
you going to put on
overseeing or checking
or monitoring resources?
Right?
So it is about scaling.
And it is about, I think,
giving autonomy to teams
and giving responsibility
to teams that build product
that they should be the
ones taking care of security
when it comes to
configuration and monitoring.
But at the same time, we
want to give them tools--
or want to give the organization
tools to scale to such size
that it is going to talk or it
is going to notify all teams
and help them
monitor their stuff.
So that is kind of security
at scale and maybe security--
or self-service security
at the same time.
That is what it means to me.
ANDREW HOYING: Adding
onto that-- so one
of the great things about
Cloud is that it enables us
to segment different workloads
in different environments.
Sort of the evolution
if you will,
of computing from mainframes
to data centers to Cloud.
As we move to Cloud,
we want to build
security sort of
in from the ground
up in a way that was difficult
to do in a data center, where
we can run each different
workload in its own environment
with its own security settings.
But as the number
of environments
you're managing scales up, you
can't scale up people to that.
You would quickly
run out of resources.
So we need tooling
to enable ourselves,
enterprises, to
run a vast number
of different environments
without needing 100 security
engineers to manage
them all, you know.
So that's really what
it's about-- scaling up
each security engineer
to be the most
valuable, the most
productive that they
can be for the enterprise.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
so Forseti's tooling
includes things like
inventory, scanner, enforcer,
and notifier.
Is that right?
ANDREW HOYING: Yes.
That's correct.
MELANIE WARRICK: And can you
explain a little bit more
about what those pieces do?
ANDREW HOYING: Sure.
So inventory is simply
the crawler that says,
look at all of the
resources that are
running in your organization.
At Google Cloud Platform,
we have a resource hierarchy
that starts from an organization
node, which is everything that
belongs to your organization.
Underneath that, you
can have folders.
Inside of those, you
can have projects.
And inside of projects,
there are running resources--
your virtual instances,
your VMs, your storage,
and everything else.
So Forseti takes and
crawls from the top down
to create a snapshot
inventory of everything that's
running in your
environment and stores
that in a Cloud SQL
storage currently.
The next bit is
the scanner, which
is a set of rules that audit
the configuration that all
those resources.
So it might look at how your
Identity and Access Management
is configured to look for,
like, someone added from outside
of your organization that
shouldn't be as having access
to a project, or look at
your virtual instances
to see if they've got external
IP addresses where they
shouldn't, or look at
your firewall rules--
any sort of configuration
that exist on Cloud.
And we're constantly adding
additional capabilities
to those scanners
so that you can
look for all of the
common best practices
as well as put in place
your own custom requirements
for how you expect things to be
configured for your enterprise.
Enforcer comes from
another internal tool
that we had called GC Enforcer.
And its purpose today is
to set firewall policy.
So if you've got a
predefined configuration
or set of configurations
that you want to push out
across all of your different--
or a subset of your
projects, enforcer
is the way to make sure
that those projects all
stay in sync with that
centrally managed configuration.
And then notifier
is the component
that takes any violations
from the scanners
as well as can be configured
to notify on some inventory
components as well.
But primarily, it's
about taking a violation
and figuring out who
the project owner is
and sending a
notification saying,
your configuration is out
of sync, and please fix it--
again, pushing some
of the security
down to the individual
teams instead of
having security engineers have
to manage every environment.
MARK MANDEL: This almost
sounds like the phrase--
I'm kind of thinking about
it as, like, as if it
was sort of a Terraform or--
ANDREW HOYING: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: --deployment
manager in Ansible,
or something like that
that's specifically
tailored to security.
So you're defining
a source of truth
of what sort of firewall rules
or IM policies or anything
like that of what should be,
and then it's up to this tool
to make sure that that
is, like, the truth.
Do you feel like that's
a good summation?
ANDREW HOYING: Yeah.
And, you know,
internally we work
with Terraform and Deployment
Manager for different projects
for maintaining their
specific security.
And for some subset of projects,
they're great tools for that
because you have sort
of-- you've defined
your configuration as code
as some kind of predefined--
this is exactly how this
system should be set up.
But as Nenad said, in an
agile natural environment,
you also have some projects
that are sort of being
developed on the fly or managed
by development teams or smaller
squads.
And having a fully managed tool
isn't always best for them.
So having something that can
come through and sort of audit
the configuration
post-deployment
is also really powerful.
And being able to do that
across all of your projects
is really the key to what
Forseti brings to the table.
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: Yeah.
And if I may add to that--
so there's also
the Enforcer piece,
and that is about opening up
your perimeter to the world.
So that one is about having
a centrally located database,
which is the source of truth
or firewall rules, which
is enforced so that it prevents
people from making mistakes.
That is the other piece.
And I think there were some
discussions about maybe
adding something for Buckets.
But then, it is maybe something
that is upcoming as a feature.
ANDREW HOYING: Right.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: But it is
about tying the loose ends.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So this sounds
really interesting.
If people, like, want to use or
configure or install Forseti,
like, how do we go
about doing that?
Is it, like-- is there
a push button installed?
Or I download it from GitHub?
What do I do?
ANDREW HOYING: Sure.
So we've got a
Deployment Wizard that's
on GitHub that sits
alongside of Forseti.
So on the website
forsetisecurity.org,
there is a number of
resources, including
the quickstart
installation guide.
But the really high
level is you start
a Cloud Shell on
a project that you
want to install Forseti into.
You run the Deployment Wizard
from within that shell,
and it walks you
through everything
to get your environment set up.
It puts all of the
resources in place
that Forseti needs
and spins up the VM
and then gives you
access to start using it.
So we've tried to
make the install as
straightforward as possible
so that you can get straight
to configuring and
using the data.
MARK MANDEL: Am I
configuring this with,
like, YAML files, or is there
a GUI, or how does that work?
ANDREW HOYING: Yes.
It's all configured with YAML
files stored in Google Cloud
Storage buckets.
So each of the
different scanners
has their own rule file
that defines your policy
for that particular resource
along with an overall
configuration file that sort of
defines what resources you're
reading into the inventory,
and what your organization is,
and what notifiers you
have enabled, et cetera.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well anyway.
So in terms of the
way it's being used,
would you also use
this in development?
ANDREW HOYING: Absolutely.
So this is a great way for
just getting a handle on--
if you're spinning up some
new resources in the Cloud,
or you're trying to
develop how you're
going to ultimately deploy
your resources in the Cloud,
having Forseti already up
and running and getting
it configured in a
development environment
prior to rolling it
out to production
is really powerful because
it can give you insights
to misconfigurations.
You know, everybody tries
to do the right thing.
But sometimes, when
we're moving fast,
we accidentally
leave some system
open to the internet,
or some other exposure
that we didn't mean to.
So having Forseti
there to notify,
hey, you've got this
configuration in place.
Did you mean to?
Is very powerful, even if it's
just a development environment.
You don't want to have
a security incident
anywhere in your organization.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sometimes those
are the things you might not
necessarily consider--
ANDREW HOYING: Right.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--that can bite you.
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: Yeah.
And I mean, to add
to that, I mean
it's usually about taking a
very holistic approach, which
is yeah.
So you actually don't
know what you're
exposing in the dev
environment or how
it's connected to production.
Maybe it's not.
But in general, you
don't know how it's
connected to your [INAUDIBLE].
So it's better to
be safe than sorry.
So you just focus of use Forseti
wherever you need to use it.
But the holistic approach
would be the best,
at least from my perspective.
And that is my advice.
And yeah.
You just go from there.
So once-- one--
I mean, you can actually test
it out in the dev environment
and how it scales up and how
you will get notifications
once it goes into production.
And then the second
one is, yes, you also
get to learn about
misconfiguration.
So you can either
automate them if you're
deploying too many instances or
in general too many resources.
And at the same time, you
know what the problem is.
So sometimes, it's
not very obvious,
but you get to learn from it.
MARK MANDEL: And this sounds
like something you'd want to--
in an ideal world,
you'd want to slot this
in as early as possible, right?
You don't want to be making
changes to your production
system in production.
You don't know
necessarily what's
going to happen-- if
it's going to lock down
certain ports, which will stop
certain things from talking
to each other or
that kind of stuff.
Would you agree?
ANDREW HOYING: Yes.
Absolutely.
The earlier you can
deploy it and start
getting the
visibility, the easier
it's going to be
to make sure you've
got all your best practices
in place from the beginning.
And when you go to
production, you're confident.
MELANIE WARRICK: Is there
anything in particular
you've seen people miss
when you-- you know,
we're talking about trying
to have a holistic approach--
the thing that, you know, seems
obvious or seems so simple,
but yet has proved to be
one of the bigger gaps?
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: We make--
yeah.
I can go from my perspective
and my learnings.
And that is sometimes
it is hard for people
to realize how different
GCP is from some competitors
without name dropping.
It's not cool.
So yeah.
Sometimes, something that
competitor has as an option
might be something
different than GCP.
So it is a big
misunderstanding to start with.
And then of course, the logic
and the business logic behind--
well, not only business
logic, but also tech logic--
behind GCP is totally
different from something else
that might be out there.
So most of those
happen because of that.
And then, of course,
having the best practices
on how things work is probably
very helpful for people.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
was going to say,
without name dropping
or necessarily talking
about other setups, is there
anything specific in GCP
that you're like, yeah, that
was very different for us
and stood out,
that comes to mind?
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: One
thing that comes to mind
would be maybe how
buckets work or--
MELANIE WARRICK: Ah the buckets.
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: GCS storage.
Yeah.
So because yes, of course.
You have the IM policy,
and all of a sudden,
it becomes a bit confusing
because maybe GCS buckets
don't follow the IM
model to start with.
And then yes.
So maybe the docs
are a bit confusing.
What is an authenticated user?
What is an org
user to start with?
And some of those
misconfigurations
happen there because it
is how users are treated.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
So Forseti was able to
help with addressing that.
MARK MANDEL: It sounds
like Forseti kind of takes
the assumption away, right?
It's like, you're very specific
about exactly how things
are, rather than just
assuming something
works in a certain way.
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: Yes.
That is correct.
But then, of course, it
is, again, up to the user
to actually decide
on how they are
going to define
the rules, right,
and what is acceptable to them.
There are some best
practices rules, but yes.
So it depends on how
they use the resources
and how they approach the
openness of the environment--
or their openness to the world.
ANDREW HOYING: I would
add to that in general,
access control policies
are difficult for someone
who is not constantly working
with them as a security
engineer.
You usually just
want to get things up
and running and working.
And so it's easy to
accidentally over-grant access
because you can't tell
necessarily that you've
over-granted access.
You can just tell
that it's working.
So having something
follow up and look
at what the actual configured
policy is against what
the expectation is
and notify people
when they have granted too
much access or over-exposed
a resource is really powerful,
both for the learning
of the individual
system owner, as well as
for maintaining the
overall security
of all of the environment.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I've seen that be a common
problem before, too.
It's just like, I can't get in.
Let's just give
access to everything.
And it's clearly the
wrong way to go, but yeah.
It's a hard one.
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: And I
mean, without overcomplicating
the answer, but it's also about
an internal security culture,
and how open the culture is,
and whether people come and talk
to the security team or
they avoid it and try
to find solutions.
And that is where maybe hacks
happen, where people just
try to solve their problem--
maybe not the right way
of solving the problem,
but it is about
solving a problem.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
We've talked about
it a little bit,
but I'd love to hear more about,
like, what happens when Forseti
finds something that doesn't
comply with the policy that's
been set up.
It sounds like there's
kind of two options.
There's an automated
fix and a notification.
Could you talk a little
bit more about those?
I know you're using
this a lot at Spotify.
Why don't you talk about
how that works at your end?
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: I can
talk about the automated
notification.
So the automated
notification is depending
on what you prefer to use.
You have several ways of
getting notified as a team.
So that can be emails,
Slack, whatever you prefer.
And of course, depending on
what policies you've enabled
and what the rules are
for those policies,
they will generate violations
on the Forseti backend.
Then as Andrew
mentioned, there's
the notifier tool, which
takes those violations
and they adjust
them-- or ingest them
to create an actual
format of a notification,
either for slack or email.
And then it also finds
the owner at the same time
and notifies the
owner, which is yes.
So for example, you own this
project, we found a violation,
let's say in your GCS storage.
And this is the actual issue,
and this is how you fix it.
So everything is
kind of configurable
on what kind of a
message you send.
And when it comes to the
automated remediation,
that is only on the
Enforcer side of things,
and it is only for
firewall rules.
So if you, by mistake,
open something
and then you have
Enforcer enabled,
it will reapply the rules
based on the centrally stored
database or centrally stored.
So those are the two
modes of operation.
MELANIE WARRICK: Can you tell
us about what's coming out?
ANDREW HOYING: Yeah.
And this is really a
great segue to some
of the new things that's
coming out here in the coming
months for Forseti.
There's going to be a new
version of Forseti that's
released here at the end
of March, early April,
which might already be
out by the time you're
listening to this, which
is the Forseti 2.0.
It's got a totally
redesigned inventory system
that crawls resources
much faster.
So it scales to a much larger
organization than 1.0 can,
or at least it
allows you to take
a snapshot of your inventory
at more frequent intervals.
And it's got a new
component in addition to
the four we've already
talked about called
IM Explainer, which allows
you to ask questions like,
who in my organization can
restart this particular VM.
And it will crawl all
of the IM Settings
across the organization
and resolve those
to a set of permissions and
then answer this set of people
can perform that action or
any other type of question
that you might have like
who can delete a resource,
or who all has access to
this database, et cetera.
So that's a very
powerful tool, especially
in complex organizations.
Without getting
too deep into it,
identity and access management
policies are hierarchical.
So policies can be set on the
organization, or on a folder,
or on a project,
or on a resource.
And the combination
of all of those
ends up being the total
set of policies that
are applied to that resource.
So it can be difficult to reason
about it without a tool like IM
Explainer.
In addition to that,
after 2.0 launches,
we've got a new set of
auditors and a new tool
called Action Engine,
which is going
to be a combination of
Enforcer and Notifier
into the single tooling.
And that Action Engine will
allow a much greater set
of resources to be
automatically remediated
than just firewall rules.
So we're very
excited about that.
That's most likely more
towards the end of June
before we're going to
see that in the product.
But that's sort of
the two big things
that we're working on
right now that we're really
excited to get out and
in front of people.
The 2.0 release candidate
one is out today,
so you can go ahead
and try it out.
And check on the
website, because 2.0
should be released here soon.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
And so if others wanted
to contribute to Forseti,
is there a place that
they can contribute?
ANDREW HOYING: Yes we very
much value the community,
and we've got contributions
from many, many different
organizations, many different
open-source individuals
already.
So our GitHub is, of course, the
source of truth for our code.
And forsetisecurity.org
has a good page
on contributing and becoming
a contributor to Forseti.
And we're always available
for taking questions.
There's a mailing list
off of that website
as well where you can email.
And we'd be very glad to work
with you on getting set up
to contribute back to Forseti.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
We're almost
running out of time,
but it's been super, super cool.
Before we finish,
do either of you
have anything you want to plug--
events, stuff that's
going on, places
people can go to learn more?
What's cool and
interesting with Forseti
that people should know
about before we finish?
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: Yeah.
So, as Andrew mentioned,
forsetisecurity.org--
place to go and
check things out.
As me being a tech
nerd, I would definitely
go to GitHub or the
GitHub page because there
are a lot of things out there.
Yeah. and I think those
are the resources.
And to add to that, if
you find it interesting,
contribute because it is
a really cool project.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And Andrew, anything to add?
ANDREW HOYING: No.
I think that pretty
much wraps it up.
There's a lot of
exciting things that
are going to be coming
out here this year.
So please stay tuned.
We're excited about where
the product's going.
And we want to hear
feedback, and we
want to hear your requirements
and what you would think
would make it better.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Nenad,
Andrew, thank you so
much for spending some time
with us this morning or evening,
I think, for either of you.
We really appreciate
you taking the time
and talking to us
all about Forseti.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, thank you.
ANDREW HOYING:
Thank you very much.
NENAD STOJANOVSKI: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you
again, Nenad and Andrew.
That was really great to
talk to you about Forseti
and hear what's going
on with the project.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Really great conversation.
A really useful tool
for automating security,
especially across multiple
projects inside Google Cloud.
MELANIE WARRICK: Security
is always very valuable.
Last thing is the
question of the week.
How would I automatically
scan the Docker images
in my Google Cloud repository
for known vulnerabilities?
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So this is a really
useful thing.
I am going to totally
massacre my teammate's name.
Fellow developer
advocate David--
I'm going to go with [INAUDIBLE]
MELANIE WARRICK: I think
we need at some point
to do, like, just a
mix of all of the names
that you've tried to say.
MARK MANDEL: David, I'm sorry
when I meet you in person soon
in the near future.
I apologize.
But anyway, David
writes an excellent--
most excellent blog
post talking about this.
So basically, the
scenario is that if you're
creating Docker images for
something like Kubernetes
or several other things that
could be potentially possible,
having a way to
automatically scan
those for potential
security vulnerabilities
is really, really useful.
What's great is that
Google Cloud Platform
has a Container Registry
vulnerability scanning service
that's currently
in alpha that is
really easy to turn on and use.
It's basically an API.
You can go into your API manager
and basically just turn it on.
And then when you go to have
a look at the images in Google
container registry, you
will actually see what
vulnerabilities have been
found-- hopefully none--
for all of the images
that you're creating,
potentially with Google
Container Builder.
Who knows.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: But it's
super easy set up.
We'll link to David's
blog post as well as
the documentation so you
can see how it all works.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
So mark, GDC was last week.
Do you feel, like, a loss here
that it's done and it's over?
MARK MANDEL: Part of
me is kind of happy.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: Now
you're going to rest.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It was great, though.
Fantastic conference.
I always love seeing a bunch
of friends, and catching up,
and stuff.
I'm not going anywhere
because I'm sleeping a lot.
What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK:
So on April 11th,
I'll be speaking about
AI at Techtonica.
And Techtonica is a
program that specifically
does tech apprenticeships with
stipends and job placement
for Bay Area women
and non-binary adults
with low incomes.
So I'll be speaking at
Techtonica on April 11th.
And then on April
14th, I will be
speaking at the Harker
Research symposium
and talking about
diversity and inclusion.
And that's a symposium
that does a lot of insights
around tech and diversity.
It will be great.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, Mark.
I think that's it
for us this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yes it is.
Thank you so much,
Melanie, for joining me
for yet another
week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.